you guys are this the film is so awesome
it's incredible and I gotta say love
seeing miss Kirby back in the mix thank
you she was a fan favorite fans rallied
to have her come back so after all these
years how did that feel that fans wanted
Kirby back in Action it felt amazing
we share a certain history
it felt like coming home it felt
um inspiring and and I mean my heart was
full my heart was exploding
um so I did this not just for me but I
did this a lot for them I I took time
off and I didn't know what I was going
to come back doing and what the first
project was going to be and then this
pop this came along and I was like
absolutely and and the fans who have
been so so loyal so spectacular and um
yeah I just I love being back why was
this the perfect first project back in
what five years ago because I have been
there before I've been there before and
it was a family experience it was an
experience with Wes and with with David
and Courtney and Nev and I mean the the
whole team that we had the whole cast
that we had it was so much fun it was
such a glorious experience and I was
hoping to experience that again here and
I absolutely did I gotta say coming back
into the mix Hayden when you first
appeared on the screen the audience was
like ah you could hear like an audible
kind of like gasp and happiness there
curb is back she back I mean there was
like this great debate though was your
character dead or was she not Ruby this
is making a move
oh did you have faith that you would
come back to the screen franchise or was
it behind you I willed myself into
existence
when I did Scream 4 I I made them
promise I was like please just like
leave it open leave it open because I
would love to come back
um and I didn't know but you never know
what you never know you've made a movie
until you're sitting in the movie
theater watching it so you don't know
what the fate of your character you
don't know the fate of it I I I I
manifested it I manifested coming back
and I loved it awesome so I've said
first project back and back in five
years your big return but another big
change is you are now a mama said scream
before you're Noah mama and your little
one is what like eight I can't even how
is that even possible I know she's
incredible did she get to come to set
and kind of I don't know is it too gory
of a sit for an eight-year-old to come
to or just hang out the trailer with Mom
well we were dealing with covid and
a little bit of war and
um yeah you know there were there were
outside
um a lot of factors yes so she needed to
stay safe
um but I she got she got all the the
calls from Mama and and she got to see
everything
um
all the behind the scenes stuff how cool
so so cool
you know this is your first rodeo with
the the chaos the scream and the
franchise here and feel so blessed to be
included
um and um but I only only learned about
Kirby after I got The Parting screamed
six and then to see that character
return and to see the reaction of people
yeah has been amazing so I'm only
putting some of that Legacy stuff
together I mean obviously I got the role
and I'd seen Scream one but then I
watched the rest of the movies but then
I meet the actors playing the characters
that I've just seen them in the movie
anyway so cool right from the beginning
this whole job has just been almost like
one Easter egg after another one thing
leads to another and uh just an
incredible group of people young actors
that just included me and everything was
amazing yeah I did it right in no
doesn't it yes I mean this is this is
family this is Legacy this is a
franchise and here you are taking on of
lead detected which was previously
assumed by David Arquette Dewey
so were you feeling like those were some
that was a big badge to film because
that is a big batch no doubt um I know
David from years ago so I always um I
always just attract his action on the
scene and uh he's obviously one of the
most favorite characters in the whole
franchise so I knew I was following on
on that as uh law enforcement for scream
sex yeah okay all right I miss David I
miss David but I could not we could not
have asked for anybody better than it
thank you mine is incredible but um I'll
tell you one of the the agent calls and
they said good call you know Scream Six
once you know I said great
um it's David Arquette still in it that
was my first question they got back to
me that afternoon with the bad news
literally I was hoping that we were cops
together but you never know when uh I
don't know like a flashback or you never
know that's correct Never Say Never we
see service in this one so you never
know
the gore in Scream 4 versus the gore and
scream six
there is no comparison right I mean the
gore is is
next level of Next Level we're in the
Red Zone like Beyond we're in the Red
Zone yeah
the kills in the movie they're really
long too so yeah even if you miss some
of it there's still people you'll still
come back to the kill yeah there's gonna
be another one Jill at it no I just mean
that it's they're bloody they're gorier
they're they're more surprising uh
potentially but they're also they're
longer it's so wild
who the hell are you who the hell are
you I'm the hell person whose office
this is
now 20 years ago I do believe you
appeared you popped up in France oh yeah
oh yeah sometimes I start something like
having to get a little nervous like I
said 20 years ago
what did I do
[Laughter]
yeah I'm good now that's so wild though
and here you are it was a good thing 20
years ago you were on friends oh there
too I was so um blessed to be invited
they were at their Peak it's the ninth
season I think so one of their uh later
Seasons
um and they put me in as um Rachel's um
replacement at work you know because she
had a maternity leave yeah and then x
amount of years later
yeah we had a little reunion did you all
reminisce about the days I did I know um
that Courtney and I agreed that my
episodes were the best episodes ever
naturally I know it was so nice that um
it actually had just been um
designated that
they've sort of taken a poll uh-huh
um and everybody agreed did that that's
weird
hundreds of episodes right yeah like 11
Seasons but those three episodes in the
ninth season somehow managed to be at
the fan favorite is the term right here
throwing around here a lot yeah
I can tell you we should swear to God
right just combine our resumes yes and
then we together accumulatively will
know everyone in the entertainment
industry probably because the half of
the people that I don't know you know
all of them yep yeah yeah
you are such a joy to be around and I am
so delighted to see you again back in
Action thank you what's next what's
what's up your sleeve next it's up there
so it's up there it's nice
but uh yeah yeah good things good things
to go
[Music]